welcome to this video playing Mike
homeworks my chromebox y'all let's see
what what happens here plate b3 and I'm
chose a conservative set up with d5
normally am playing if I but this looks
like a decent setup so that seemed I'm
trying to play me five at the later
stage fighting for the square oh wait
not to cook if I take him we can take
with the pawn and use the F file so
probably this one yeah now it's
difficult for him to maintain the night
yeah so he moved it yeah come on let's
guess along if he takes I can even take
with the Jeep all interesting
okay I have to do that in the long run
let's see maybe Roxy 193 this kind of
stuff it feels like black should be ok
here for very decent pieces hmm what
Defour young go for activity yeah five
maybe Nigeria of course okay jack ad for
was probably not so well timed not bad
but not really am too promising the
knight on c3 didn't have any great rule
well okay but it's not the problem
really if it takes f6 i play rookie six
and the night doesn't really have a
great square and ideas to take III and
then Bishop c5 putting crush on the
three Pawn hmm
yeah I this I didn't expect if I take on
III Queen takes I booking form and night
takes I have rope the eighth yeah okay
my idea is to get it to be six maybe
also route d8 and droopy 8b 6 is the
best possible square for this piece
attacking of the ìiî pound are putting
pressure on the pot here we go he is
protected it yeah that's that's agree
move really
no I come off you cannot take that bone
really if i play f6 sir where do you go
with this night Queen f5 I cannot
believe it come on I'm trapping the
night now don't tell me you have a great
way to save it rook age three maybe but
this looks like looks strange
if I go Rocky seven Knight f6 I take on
h3 take only 3 s's the straw yeah i
think it is strong 90 f 6 rook takes h3
and then work takes III if you give this
check i can take it and I'm enduring
peace up at the end 97 ichat egg Queen
takes rookie 7 check winning would wait
wait we just just just briefly they are
can its strong enough it's strong enough
I don't need to look for an alternative
check
can turn his bone structures also really
wrecked let's let's see I probably i'll
need the king so activate the king check
yeah this looks safe the king of
locating the pawn and you know stem mate
I made somewhere don't really see one ok
let's just try to pick up the porn
d 5 rupees fight Ozai yes no no counter
play at all ya got a good trick him I
don't I don't really know this deform
with it if this was good guide
immediately introduces technical plane
may be here I should have taken the
other look it's much more logical to be
honest yeah well came I played that one
I know he came up with this funny Queen
d3 move ok I took and now that one we
yeah don't really know what to make a
make of this position computer just
wants to take something like that and
gives widen edge yeah it's possible it's
a pawn yeah it's not clear what I have
for the pond yeah that was bit strange
look de 8 just the other one yeah what
this girl looks looks quite nice to be
honest at least I like it oh now 97 well
this I completely overlooked check this
is this is strong of course he gets rid
of of my my bishop nitey 195 is also
interesting the idea being that you have
this square yeah many good good ways for
white to play but this is just a mistake
after six this was too greedy no just
lost i think yeah it's minus 4 comp is
pretty strict here just I'm just winning
the peace or you get to the stuff that
happened in the game check ya King a8 is
even stronger but ok piece is a piece
and it's
this is fairly easy to do i check this i
have this this double check threat so
yeah it's hard for him to find a square
for the Queen where it is not lost
probably it's impossible to find the
square yeah computer actually wants to
do to this move kakoj gives up the Queen
yeah well okay the other one what I
played 10 piece which is fine as long
alright thanks for watching